the pilgrimage church of v's near  Steingarten is considered a rococo  masterpiece it's colorful exuberant and  joyful it took nearly 10 years for its  master builders the brothers johann  baptist and dominicos zimmerman to  finish it for its consecration in 1754 a  celebrated architect dominicos also saw  to the characteristic stucco  ornamentation  but it was his elder brother who painted  the Magnificent ceiling fresco  the reason this lavishly decorated  church was built was to house this  relatively inconspicuous wooden figure  which is said to have once shed tears  the pilgrimage church of the scourge  Savior as it's also known has been a  UNESCO World Heritage Site since 1983  you